what happened with 911 in the nsa act
where they started monitoring potential
terrorists
so are these people considered potential
terrorists who knows but they would
still be able to purchase firearms if
you're
a citizen of the u.s i thought it was
for the patriot act and that's one of
the
i changed my mind yeah um no
time for a new installment of change my
mind where we rationalize
our positions on controversial topics as
always comment which topics you'd most
like to see in the future
today well you've all heard former vice
president joe biden talk about this in
recent days
gun control are you proposing taking
away their guns and how would this work
i am we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
and you shouldn't be able to exploit
loopholes
and evade criminal background checks by
buying
online or at a gun show to gun owners
out there who
say well a blind administration means
they're going to come for my guns
bingo if i'm elected and are i'm coming
for you
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
we all know the proposed gun control is
unconstitutional there's no such thing
as a gun show loophole
and assault weapons it's not a thing
this time on campus when i showed up
everyone was having a good time
oh piss off i didn't say i liked people
but just for that i prefer tcu
you must have never had a frog leg in
your life
was frog leg is that a thing what i'm
french canadian
we have frog legs at our golden corrals
forgotten
they're not even joking it's a place
called newport and vici's which had to
be shut down for gross healthcare
violations
they had frog legs it was like a first
station
is that a thing like what's the tcu smu
crockett
the dining halls
i'm sorry i'm not privy to your your
local regional sports
references for crying out loud then go
to schenectady oh yeah
you know about the uh yellow tree what
i'm told
[Laughter]
so good in fact that the local cops
arrived tried to kick us out said we
couldn't film there
then i realized it was a public park
last i checked the first amendment still
applies
so i did it anyway what are they gonna
do well you'll see nothing
here's evan oh you're evan okay hey evan
nice to meet you
sir all right
so evan do you mind moving in a little
bit just yeah yeah all right i don't
know you think that uh i'm not hitting
on you anything
so uh we've done broad sort of general
i'm pro second amendment champion
uh like i was saying earlier we didn't
expect uh
the executive or the executive order so
we didn't change a sign but these are
the executive orders right
here if you're not familiar with them um
you can peruse them because we want to
make sure that
look i'm not what we do i don't know how
familiar the last thing i want to do is
like i gotcha
yeah and i don't exactly expect everyone
to be familiar with them so you can kind
of look at them
uh and i think that it's nonsense
particularly
from what i understand that you're a fan
of is the uh the national red flag
yeah i do want to talk about that all
right
so clarification question with this red
flag law does that not make a national
mandate of a red flag law in 60 days
or they can't make a match this is
basically sort of setting a template
and then eventually they're going to try
and a lot of it is executive orders and
then some of it is also pushing
congress for example they want people to
be pushing legislation manufacturers
they want that was something but i don't
think you could do that through
executive action but then
the national red flag law you know he's
trying to exert pressure and he wants to
start with a
template yeah yeah so my opinion is that
we should have a national red flag law
and obviously
the process for it needs to be like
regulated through a court system
to make sure that it was just fully like
enforced
to take their gun like take the guns
away and i would assume that you would
believe that that is government overstep
um well i think we already have that
system in place it's not a red flag law
okay what is that then so have you
purchased firearms yes okay so you know
about the background check yeah you go
through okay
so you know so i i think we're starting
off on common ground then because
at the time when he gave executive
orders he said people buying guns
without background checks
that's not true you know it's not true i
know it's not true um and with that
background check they're making sure
that you are
of age right they're making sure that
you're not a criminal right now in this
country you cannot purchase a firearm
legally
if you're a felon if you're a violent
domestic abuser or if you've already
been
adjudicated mentally defective uh by a
judge or court of law
i think those are pretty good standards
and i think if we want to talk about
filling in the gaps
i would be open to hearing how you would
do that and it not be a violation of
constitutional rights
but this right here uh goes far beyond
that scope i mean i think that's a
pretty good standard yeah
where we know okay felony we agree
domestic violence that's a
violent domestic views that's violence
for example like he also said like oh
you know domestic music if you're
talking about like people getting into a
tussle
or people being verbally abusive that's
very different from an actual violent
domestic abuser you can't legally
purchase a firearm
and then if you've been by a court order
ajudicated mentally defective you can't
purchase a firearm
how would you add to that i guess so
what i would add to that is
first of all the reason for it is like
you say
constitutional overstep like personal
rights overstuffed by the government
and with all the gun violence that's
happened this year as
you probably know it's been like four
times the national average like
in previous years and so violence period
yeah yeah not gun violence
okay so i would say that that is
similar i wouldn't say it's like
perfectly the same to what happened with
911
in the nsa act where they started
monitoring potential terrorists
so are these people considered potential
terrorists who knows but they would
still be able to purchase firearms if
you're
a citizen of the u.s yeah and you can
pass that background check because by
the
way
i i thought it was for the patriot act
and then that's one of the i changed my
mind yeah um
no okay
yeah so a couple of i'm just trying so
no to the patriot act notice spying on
americans
and uh no to everything you just said
let me explain to you why okay
crime has been consistently going down
right yeah crime is going down before
the assault weapons ban is going down
after the assault weapons ban
we have one year with a blip oh wait a
year in 2016 with a blip
and this last year with a blip okay you
said it was gun crime it's not
it's for the same reason there were two
billion dollars just in business damages
hundreds of officer casualties dozens of
murders
and thousands of arrests at the riots
that took place over the summer
alone okay i'm not disagreeing with you
the homicide rate went up
2 000 in portland i'm not disagreeing
with you that the violent crime went up
over 100 percent in places like new york
and minneapolis or milwaukee
where they defunded the police but to
suggest that that's because of
uh law-abiding american citizens who own
firearms i mean there's a reason that
more black americans have purchased
firearms in the last year
than ever in american history and i
don't think that stripping people
who are the victims of these riots and
this increasing violent crime
is a solution okay okay
uh i mean is that fair yeah that's fair
would you agree with me that
there wasn't a sudden rise in just angry
white mass shooters that there is a
correlation with
one year spike and that can be directly
i mean
traced to the defunding of police the
allowing of violent riots
i mean i i would say that
that's a tough one i'm just trying to
get my thoughts together um well look
i'll tell you this
assume i'm not lying statistically it's
undeniable yeah yeah it was the most
violent song i believe that you're
telling me the truth or the summer of
love as i said in seattle oh god
yeah so i still
it's still about the psychiatric
background i know that
gun violence might not have gone up but
i still think it's a problem
so how can we fix that and there are
loopholes as you would probably know
what loopholes
well you said first off you said you
support the red yes
national red flag do you want to talk my
yes proposal
so yeah why do you support a red flag
law beyond what we already know which is
right
just i need to clarify so felon violent
domestic abuser
mentally by a court you want to add to
that with a red flag
why uh i would like to add to that so
um doctors if they know that their
patient is a harm to themselves
they have to report that to the police
if they mention anything of that
so why are they then allowed to
continue to have their guns if they know
they are a danger to themselves
because just because you're reporting to
the police doesn't mean anything's going
to happen
right so and you know something like
you're saying that's it sounds
like you're saying if a doctor reports
to the police they should immediately
come and take your guns away
no no no i think there should be due
process and that there should be
like it would have to be proven through
like psychiatric evaluation
that these people are suicidal are
trying to
like hurt some other people than in like
a mass shooting type thing
but you would have to show evidence with
it and not just have it be
like yeah you just argued against red
flag laws
that's fair no no seriously like you
just targeted that's what mentally
adjudicated mentally defective so the
process
is but self-harm right you report it and
it goes through a process
the red flag laws and by the way this is
sort of funny you brought up a doctor i
have some examples here we'll have all
the sources on the website
just again just assume i'm not lying to
you there's a doctor i believe was in
new jersey new york
who actually had uh his patient because
he wrote bad
yelp reviews had his guns taken away
yeah so again that's why you like you're
saying you need those processes of
okay and we have those that's why a
court needs to deem you
you know adjudicated mentally defective
is the term a court needs to deem you
however the red flag laws that are
proposed
and i think what we're having here is
you maybe are thinking red flag laws or
something
different because if you're saying hey
someone who has already displayed
a violent behavior or harmful behavior
and it's proven through a system of
evidence
and they go through a process where i
would assume that you're saying
they can uh they can face their accusers
yeah right yes however red flag law is
someone reports you they can come and
take your guns in the middle of the
night
there's no trial you've been charged
with no crime no evidence
and you don't get to face your accusers
and then after a certain amount of time
you go to court and maybe they'll let
you get them back okay do you think
that just because someone hasn't
committed a violent act yet that they
should still keep their guns until they
do
uh yeah i think that if someone has not
caused harm to someone else or
themselves or it has not been proven
like you just said a psychiatric
evaluation and then facing your accusers
right yeah which is something that we
already
have yes i don't think that you minority
report and take someone's gun
someone guns pre-crime do you do you
think you should be able to take them
pre-crime
because then who determines i think
that's criminal act i think it's then in
the sense of national
security like the patriot act where
if they are planning on committing these
like crimes
and they have been proven through these
processes like how many people
with that but we already have that as my
point right right right
law is beyond proving it right the whole
point is right now this can be proven
for example
if you make a death threat yeah that's
not red flag law you can bring that into
court
if someone has started hurting
themselves right someone attempted
suicide
that's in court right away if someone
already is a felon tried to harm someone
else
then we go through the court system red
flag laws completely bypass the court
system
and put first off police lives in danger
because they're going and taking guns
think about it who don't know who don't
know they always kill the dog you know
that happens all the time how many times
do you see a report and i'm a dog lover
i don't know about you so they kill the
dog they take your guns
and uh then maybe at some point even
though you've been charged with no crime
you may get your guns back
do you think you think that's okay
because no that's not what i'm arguing
so
i didn't exactly know that before um
coming in here but
i think that we need to open up the
psychiatric evaluations more
in our current systems because i
personally don't know how
many people get like court adjudicated
like insane to where they can't have
guns
and there's probably a disproportionate
amount of people
who are insane that just haven't gone
through that system yet that need to be
filtered out
through the system i think i think
you're pro listen i think you're
probably right that there are probably
some people out there who are mentally
uh okay i say defective unstable
okay all right i'm gonna go with
defective uh but yes mentally unstable
people
who we don't know yet but here's the
issue we just had someone come out here
not the only issue but this is something
to me and i would like you to entertain
this thought for a second
the person who sat down before you emily
said that we need to have
more mental health care in this country
yeah and i agree with someone who
suffered from depression my whole life
i think that we need to uh destigmatize
seeking help
i don't think we need to glorify mental
health issues for example i don't want
to be considered a hero because i have
depression it's something i have to deal
with
however let me give you this situation
these red flag laws like as you see
proposed right this is from the white
house website again this is
not mine you can go to the white house
dot gov and read it or um
that's it might be from their briefing
room yeah yeah no problem um
someone who has concerning thoughts
maybe let's say someone who is very
depressed someone who has considered not
wanting to live anymore someone who's
embarrassed about their mental health
issues
um do you think they're more or less
likely to seek help if they know that
their constitutional right to protect
themselves could be taken away if they
admit to their mental health
shortcomings
[Music]
you'll discourage people from seeking
out help yeah but
can i bring up something else of course
uh so
if you sign up for in most states where
medical marijuana is legal
once you receive your card you can no
longer legally purchase
a firearm yeah which i think is
ridiculous i mean it's a problem with
federal laws and statements
yeah and so
does that make people who would like to
use medical marijuana to treat
themselves does that deter them from
doing it because they won't be able to
have their firearms
well they just lie and so that's my
issue right exactly
people just so there's a loophole agree
there's no point for a red flag law
people just lie
exactly yeah so it doesn't sound like
you're advocating red flag laws
you're advocating what we have yes and a
process
to make it more thorough right
which i understand costs money and takes
time
right which isn't very efficient but i
think it's what's
needed like what's necessary but you
would agree that the red flag what we're
talking about
because i think you maybe had this sort
of perceived idea of what a red flag law
was
i could barely overhear you while you
were talking to george and that's where
i got it from well george doesn't
i don't know if he's still here george
doesn't stop talking
um but what you perceived a red flag law
to be but i
just want to make sure that i understand
that now understanding that a red flag
law means that your family member
your friends your doctor can have people
take your guns away
not being charged with a crime not
facing your accusers no due process
you'd be against that i'd be against
that okay so you're against biden's
proposal
yeah but but i also i support what
you're saying yeah
you're saying too those people should be
able to still go
to the court system and mention like put
in a formal
thing that these people are unstable and
then make them go through processes
because
just because you haven't gone to see
a psychiatrist whenever you have
schizophrenia doesn't mean you don't
have schizophrenia it's true
and just because the jls ex-girlfriend
says yes schizophrenia doesn't mean you
have schizophrenia
true but i think you should still be
checked well i think
i think that there should be uh a
process which is not incredibly invasive
otherwise you would just have everyone
who's a lover scorn saying
schizophrenia you know you have
schizophrenia you're crazy you're crazy
right there needs to be a track record
and look there i think we would also
have to accept that living in a free
society
you're never going to catch everyone and
i think that it's a far greater sin
and this is something i think has never
talked about considering that there's
half a million on the low end to 3
million defensive uses of firearms
each year in this country and there are
only 14 000 homicides
each year in this country way higher in
a black lives matter peaceful summer
mind you
i think it's a far greater sin to take
away
firearms from the overwhelming number of
people who use them responsibly and
defensively
yeah in order to try and catch something
and look you're never going to have a
perfect society it's a needle in a
haystack
probably it is a needle in hand but i do
agree with you yeah in that if a doctor
can recommend it and someone
is goes through the court system i think
for me what's super important i think we
both agree here is
yeah is there needs to be due process a
charge
and the ability to face your accuser and
in this case defend yourself
and defend yourself yeah yeah um that's
not what they're proposing and
to me it's terrifying yeah i understand
that yeah evan
yes evan evan i appreciate it i think we
just came to some common ground
i think i think i somewhat changed your
mind
by accident by accident can you hear me
can you give me a hug no all right
thanks
joke's on you i have povich would you
look at that evan inadvertently changed
his mind there's plenty more to get to
but i want to let you know that none of
these episodes take place without your
support and especially now that the
entire channel
has been demonetized indefinitely
consider going to crowdershop.com
get yourself some slick threads uh we've
got some cool new designs dropping soon
thank you so much for the support no
foreign caliphate
we're funded by viewers like you
actually
on with the show i'm sorry what was your
name again george george that's right
george
how's it spelled g-o-r-g-e okay because
it's also we have a friend george
j-o-r-g yeah jorge but he said he
prefers george
fair enough um so they announced six uh
executive actions
and um then some proposals to congress
that they would like to see past
you ask me which one is most concerning
to me
so let me just sort of uh set this for
people who are tuning in
we've done pretty generic or i should
say um
i guess i should say more broad to
change my minds in the second amendment
i wanted to try and focus on some of
these new laws because a lot of people
haven't been
talking about yeah no that's why i asked
because i actually don't even know about
them either okay
so the one i think that you were talking
which one is most concerning to me is
red flag laws and if you want to read
this
do you mind reading it out loud i mean
you can read it for yourself it would
help if you read it out loud so it's
this one right here
all right uh red flag laws allow family
members or law enforcement to petition
for a court order
temporarily barring people in crisis
from accessing firearms
if they present a danger to themselves
or others the president urges congress
to pass an appropriate national red flag
law as well as legislation incentivizing
states to pass red flag laws of their
own
in the interim the justice department's
published model legislation will make it
easier for states
that want to adopt red flag laws to do
so right so could you go over like the
implications of that like what
so um first off do you want me would it
help if i expound upon the count
yeah please okay so what a red flag and
it varies from state to state
uh but that's why he wants to eventually
he's expressed the interest in having a
nationalized form of federal red flag
law
and what that means is effectively there
are gaps
right now right between for example if
you're a felon or if you're
a violent domestic abuser you cannot
purchase firearms
right what red flag laws aim to do is
expand that where
a family member a neighbor a doctor
could report well not even just related
for example there have been some doctors
or
work associates could report you
as someone who may be a danger to
yourself or others
and so in that case um the government
could seize your firearms
then i do see why that's concerning yeah
well the argument let me give you the
argument that they present is
you know if you look at um i can't
remember what shooting because i know
they sort of bleed together i think it
was
uh the one in el paso uh but there were
several shootings where they said well
they called the fbi
right and this person shouldn't have had
a firearm okay and so red flag laws
would allow us to close that gap where
it's this person's dangerous
they can be reported and their firearms
can be what they would argue temporarily
removed
so if people are reporting a person
right yeah like do they have to
like is it on certain grounds that it
has to be like legitimized like do you
like what's the process that's the
question okay right that varies from
state to state for example i think it
was in new jersey you had a
a doctor flag one of his patients
because he kept leaving him negative
reviews on yelp
and uh the guy had his firearms removed
so this is the issue right is it
it varies across some states and many
states don't have red flag laws at all
but no because i think it's pretty clear
right if you've committed a felony
or if you're a violent domestic abuser
that's another little bait and switch
that biden pulls like domestic abusers
shouldn't be able to get uh
firearms if you're a violent domestic
abuser you already can't if we're
talking about someone who got into a
verbal argument with their wife
you don't i don't believe that you
remove their ability to own a firearm
but no it's uh
it is subjective and the issue that i
have with it that's most concerning is
they take your firearms right there's no
due process
okay you're not even charged with it you
don't have to be charged with a crime
enough to be charged no you don't have
to be charged with any crime
let alone convicted you don't have to
have been even mentally diagnosed or
adjudicated defective
and you are not even there for the
hearing you have no opportunity to face
your accusers
then several weeks later what they said
several weeks later you'll have a
hearing where you're allowed to make
your case for getting your firearms back
so it's after you've already been
punished it's after they've been taken
away yeah
yeah no i do feel like that's an
abridgement of the second amendment
rights
that's that's why i wanted to ask about
red flag because i actually hadn't heard
about it i
yeah i understand your concern then
right and i i understand the reason that
people
would think it's a good idea because
they go well those people are mentally
insane i mean it's different because
like if a doctor
i guess notices a potential danger that
their patient might pose
like i don't know i see it being
justified if it's something like you
have a patient that's
schizophrenia or something right right
someone that
could pose a danger but i feel like
they would need to have already
expressed yes exactly a potential
to harm others in order for you to like
legitimately take away their firearm
right and and we kind of already have
that standard of
crime right fellaini so this is just
more on top of it yeah and i think also
you know we say a lot of people say well
we have a mental health crisis in this
country
well let me ask you this let's say
you're suffering from depression let's
say you're suffering from you know i
have
family members who have bipolar disorder
but they're not violent yeah do you
think that knowing if your doctor says
this guy's bipolar and they could take
your guns away do you think it would
make people
more likely or less likely to seek
mental health assistance
definitely less yeah you know what i
mean like we've all had rough times like
i've suffered from depression in my life
i talk about it pretty openly but i know
that if i knew
that someone a doctor could subjectively
say danger to himself
i'd probably keep it to myself so it's
these laws of you know
the rules of unattended consequences for
the clause got it and uh
does it surprise you that you haven't
heard more about it honestly considering
i mean yeah that does seem pretty
sweeping i'm kind of surprised i haven't
heard about it
yeah well this is this is from the
website and we make them all this is
from the white house website their own
press briefing are there uh like what
else
was in this ghost guns ghost guns okay
ghost guns in there that's a big thing
that's the word now ghost gun
you have a problem with ghost guns you
tweeted about them right
i don't have a problem with coasters you
don't have a problem no i just say ghost
guns are not
it's not really as far as it being an
actual threat right now an existential
threat to the united states
america the way i understand ghost guns
is that they're like you have different
parts right and then they're assembled
but it's not serialized it's not like
recognized federally in some sort of
registry i feel like that does pose a
danger right well there is no federal
registry
or not our federal reserve no but this
is important because the serial number
uh it can only trace the firearm to its
original point of sale
it doesn't trace individual individuals
so i think that matters and people start
off with it and what it is and if you
look at the actual legislation you look
what he
put especially before he ran for office
right the idea of
ghost guns first off it's it's legal for
you to make firearms at home it's not
very difficult
you have you have some piping and some
copper wire you can make a shotgun
pretty damn easily
believe me i've had friends do it i
wouldn't recommend it
sure yeah that's legal though you just
can't sell them now here's the issue
with ghost guns as they're saying you
know
you can buy a receiver you can buy an
upper and effectively you can put
a gun together with kits however you
look at their proposed follow
well proposed auxiliary legislation it's
basic it basically makes it impossible
to purchase
any gun parts online because it could be
used for a ghost gun yeah but what if i
have a safety that's broken
no i might not be able to replace the
safety what if i want to change the
display
to wherever you originally bought the
gun in order to do that right
no not if you make it difficult and
illegal to purchase parts under the
guise of the main ghost guns
and that is proposed wait but okay like
if you want to buy a safety for say like
or let's say like a slide lock or
whatever it is but
yeah the point is they would they want
to make it increasingly difficult
to purchase fire parts okay if you did
want that
and you want to do that legally safely
whatever can you not just go to where
you originally bought the gun
i'm confused no not if you want to cut
not if you want to customize your gun
not if you want to change something on
your gun for example
what extent so for example i have a
revolver okay
uh that i really like and i have i have
some guns that you know more for
practical purposes and some that are
sort of heirlooms and the trigger was
pretty rough and so i got a trigger
spring kit and i switched out the
trigger i did a trigger job
that's the kind of thing which could
very much be illegal
under the guise of ghost guns which
don't make up any percentage as far as
we know
of crimes committed right now and that's
the fault
is the idea that well these crimes are
being committed out there right now with
these ghost guns ghost guns
in other words i want you to think
there's this epidemic of guns out there
that people are creating or 3d printing
it's just not true okay it's just not an
actual threat
matter of fact the closest thing that i
found was they said 30 so i was trying
to do research on this
and it's impossible to find the closest
number you find is they say well 30 of
all guns now recovered
according to atf for ghost guns i said
well that's a lot and i realized almost
30
of all guns recovered in california were
ghost guns and so i was sitting there
trying to find some data saying well
that's interesting good amount of guns
though right
if it were true yeah so i was sitting
there going well that's interesting
that's
only in a gun free state effectively gun
restrictive state like california
here's what the truth is first off
there's no official report
it was a verbal report given to an nbc
reporter from the atf
okay and what they were saying was 30 of
all guns recovered
usually from crimes in california were
unserialized
meaning that that also includes guns
that were bought out of the back of a
truck where they would have scrubbed the
serial number which is all illegal
firearms
so that's used as the basis and i
encourage you to research it no
paper paper thin that's literally why i
sat down like i don't know that much
about this i
wanted to see because here's the thing
like i'm on the left
but i'm also pro-gun okay like i
definitely respect people's rights to
have a gun
but i mean i do feel like something like
ghost guns do
potentially present a danger you know
i just potentially present a danger
however
and then for looking into this sort of
risk reward ratio potential dangers
would you also agree that there's a
potential danger in giving
the federal government the authority to
ban
which parts are allowed to be purchased
for the fire sure yeah i mean like i
would have to research it
yeah although yeah especially when you
know that it's based on a dishonest
premise
you know i mean we have a president out
there right now who when he issued these
executive actions if you watch his
conference
said we need background checks you said
you're pro-gun do you own any firearms i
don't know
so you've never gone and purchased a
firearm i've never purchased firearms
okay do you know that they
all require background yes yes so when
you have a president who
listen i i'm not in the business of
describing motive
but i've got to believe that the
president knows that there are
background checks for guns
so i've got to say that there aren't yes
i did not know that okay
yeah he said in barack obama they said
they're the loopholes the online
loophole
if you mean that you buy a gun illegally
that's not a loophole
if you mean that you just go and buy a
gun outside of a gun show in a trunk
that's not a loophole
go to any place here that sells firearms
any gun shop
any gun dealer and they will require
a background check and a photo
identification so
when he predicates his physician on a
lie like that regal that's not true
anyone who's purchased a gun knows it's
not true
and then they use numbers like a huge
percentage of ghost guns and you go
home a second that's not true and then
the package the totality comes with
and you can't have magazines over 10
rounds we can no longer sell gun parts
and red flag laws right that's that's
really concerning to me
okay and so um yeah i would encourage
you to
and i appreciate you guys toward the
left but uh sitting down having
conversations this is the kind of stuff
that doesn't happen enough
like i'm to the left of democrats left
like yeah yeah
um
would you put me in the gulags if you
had your choice definitely not because i
also believe in individual liberties so
well he can't be that far left no i it's
never existed in any leftist country
that's existed
i would tell you research libertarian
socialism you might learn some things
i know plenty about libertarian
socialism
anarcho-socialism and i think that these
are oxymorons and make noises
yeah i wish i could talk to you about
that because i totally don't think they
are
i feel like you can have you can have
liberty
okay pause one second because maybe we
can talk about this i just want to make
sure no one else wants to talk about the
gun
and then uh is anyone hey is anyone else
looking to talk about firearms
so this is where george and i wrapped
our conversation on common sense gun
control but don't worry
we'll have another segment with george
on libertarian socialism coming soon
spoiler alert he didn't actually change
my mind but before we go on to our final
guest
uh i had to take a moment to deal
with this beautiful brave young woman i
just want to ask how is my face
pollution
it's not really nice oh i don't want to
talk to you i know but that's pretty
rude
i can literally leave i don't want to
talk to you i just got into grad school
i'm not talking to you
you just find why i'm not talking to you
but i'm just curious when you say like
someone's
oh okay all right it's a joke okay it's
a joke and it's because you disagree
with me
yes it was a joke i'm gonna face this
pollution i don't want to be feeling so
no it's okay look well you're being
filmed because you're in a public area i
just want to make sure that you're okay
with that homonym
as well okay
but by the way we didn't expect former
vice president joe biden to declare war
on the second amendment
over the weekend so we had to
do an impromptu sign change yes we're
just that crafty and our penmanship is
that awful now on to emily
emily you wanted to talk about firearms
so i wanted to say you know we have this
general
um i'm pro second amendment change my
mind which is more broad
however uh we just changed the sign
right now that's why it's written
um like andy from toy story under buzz's
shoe
we didn't expect by new issue sweeping
executive actions
and so i wanted to specifically talk
about this in relation to
what is proposed as common sense gun
reform which of course
i believe is nonsense um particularly as
it relates to joe biden's executive
actions now are you familiar with the
ones he just issued
can i take a look at yes absolutely so
this is from the white house uh directly
and the ones in bold
those are kind of the actual actions and
then there's descriptions of them
and if i understand you specifically
wanted to discuss mental health in the
issue of guns but
you know if you want to read these uh no
rush you can peruse them
does it say what these strategies are
it's kind of like the green new deal
thing where then it's just
everything they're after and uh give us
your money
the thing is obviously we should have
gun laws because you can't just buy a
gun willy-nilly
right but this seems a little dude
this seems ridiculous in the sense that
it's not actually
creating any change okay i'm gonna put
this on top not to
to uh hide it from you but just to make
sure that it doesn't blow away
it seems ridiculous that joe biden is is
using his executive orders almost like
what's the right word a dick
i wouldn't say it like that okay i'm
sorry in in a sense that it's almost
like
abusing this yeah you shouldn't it
for the wrong reasons because what it
really is is it's a mental health issue
so they should be doing mental health
advocacy in schools instead of this if
they're really worried about
school shootings and things like that
yeah you go to the root of the problem
it's not guns but we should we should
have gun control
but we do i mean i know a lot of people
that have guns that don't have a gun
license especially here in texas and
you need a gun license but you shouldn't
have to have a gun license i'm saying
when you purchase a firearm
you have to get a bat you go through a
background check you can't be a criminal
or a violent domestic abuser
well why shouldn't we have gun license
like instead of
instead of like like in the same sense
of like a driver's license
yeah well because driving is not a
constitutional right
but i mean you need id to purchase a
firearm just as you need id
you should need id to vote um
so i think that you should have to
present identification to make sure that
we know you're of age
we know that you're not a criminal we
know that you're a legal citizen but if
you have you ever purchased a firearm
i have not okay so we actually did this
one time where we didn't change my mind
and
there were a couple of lovely ladies who
were to the left
and uh they didn't know about this and
so we went to go purchase a firearm with
them we took them to the range kind of
educated them a little bit
and then i said hey which one did you
prefer and they preferred this firearm
of author ppq
and they uh attempted to purchase it
with a long background check
turned out they couldn't because she
wasn't 21. so 21 for a pistol in texas
uh you can be 18 for a long gun so no we
have we already have background checks
if you want to uh conceal carry in some
states like texas you need a permit
see that's all fine with me but the
issue is
the issue is it's like it's mental
health
so i just want to make sure we have
comments so you it doesn't sound to me
like
yeah that law-abiding citizens should be
able to purchase firearms
okay and i don't i kind of think it like
hinders somebody's rights but the fact
that like
i know that i know some people that are
schizophrenic that have a gun
and i don't think that should be allowed
and is that part of the is that part of
the
is that part of the background check or
is it not well no you have to be so
again there's a standard and this is the
problem with red flag laws you have to
be i believe the term is
uh adjudicated mentally defective by a
court because look okay
i know people i have let's say friends
and or relatives who have bipolar
disorder
they should absolutely be allowed to own
a fire yeah because you're a functioning
member of society when you have not all
well yeah not all some of them have
severe bipolar disorder some of them
have bipolar disorder uh that is not
i mean like when it gets to a point of
severity then then i think that there
maybe should be somebody checking in on
that well i think there should be people
checking in on that and that's the issue
where again you're talking about the
severity of a court order
and particularly it that's pretty easy
uh to substantiate
if this person has already uh either
committed a crime or even a step further
committed an act that was very clearly
dangerous to themselves or others but
maybe not necessarily a crime
you know what i mean that's something
that would be on the record um
the issue with for example red what
you're talking about is mental health
and so they use that to sort of warp it
into red flag laws the issue there
i think that's wrong yes but a lot of
that is it's predicated on the idea of
mental health they go well look
we have a mental health problem and so
why can't family and doctors flag people
with mental health issues it's like
yeah but now your rights are removed
even though you've not been charged with
a crime
and you haven't been able to face your
accusers you lose due process
it's like they're almost manipulating uh
mental health just for their own gain
and jordan not george greg abbott passed
some law
like i think last year in texas schools
they were like okay we care about mental
health
but in reality it was just like an
elective it was basically just for show
okay so i guess my my question is do you
mean you think that mandatory mental
health
courses would so i think either in
in schools i think definitely in high
schools and middle schools you should
have a either
course or you should have a licensed
psychiatrist or a licensed psychologist
on campus at all times that's actually
trained and like actually knows what
they're talking about and actually
provides a safe space for children
yeah and that's what we need in the
schools and if you did that in every
single school
school shootings would go down i think
if you had armed security guards in
every single school and because that's
the one thing that's very consistent you
know it's like
anywhere from the low end 95 to high in
98
of all mass shootings and current gun
free zones
so places like schools churches i don't
really think that a social worker is
gonna
well i mean the schools here have armed
um some of them
my my high school did but
the thing is i think it's almost making
it a safe space for children
and i don't think necessarily an armed
guard versus a psychiatrist or a trusted
like mental health advocate but if
someone wants to go into that school
and shoot it up you don't think that
space is safer by having armed guards
it is safer but i think you can make it
even safer by having mental health
because the kids that are
the people that are shooting up schools
they're the children that go to those
schools
yeah yeah well a lot of these cases by
the way lies kids one of the
commonalities too is like the
the strongest correlation and i know i
took humanity's 101 to correlation
causation but when you look at 95 98
occur in gun-free zones another one uh
is the vast majority something
like 80 to 90 something percent of these
mass shooters didn't have fathers in the
home
and that doesn't get uh fixed by
psychologists in school but it could
help it could help
it could help but i think if we're
getting to the root cause of the issue
particularly with mental health
really what we need to talk about is the
nuclear family unit and the proper
rearing of children it starts with
families
before we get to communities or public
schools i mean look if more funding
more resources and public schools would
solve this problem
then you know the best schools in the
country would be places like chicago or
detroit or washington dc
it's a system that just doesn't it goes
into a black hole that is government
i think we need to take it upon
ourselves and what concerns me with laws
i guess it seems like we agree
is this again bestows more power to the
government to remove people's individual
rights
i have no problem with having
psychologists on campus
i do have a problem with where we say
mental health someone shouldn't be
allowed to purchase a firearm
outside of the realm of what we have
which is officially adjudicated mentally
defective
because not long ago gender dysphoria
was considered a mental illness yeah and
now gender dysphoria is just considered
the symptoms
of gender identity disorder however it
still comes with a 42
attempted suicide right right
transgenders doesn't get any better if
they go through the surgery and hormone
replacement
nowhere else so do we say well you're
transgender you can't have a firearm
because you're 42 likely to attempt
suicide no you shouldn't go off of those
things
i think what you said about the the
court-ordered thing i think is
is a good standard a good standard
because it already exists but but you're
talking about helping
improve mental health period regardless
of laws yes regardless of laws what it
would do is just
it would just reduce the amount of
children that are
at the point where they need to do
something horrible
i think so too and i think but more
important before that is having parents
in the household
yes but i think it an easier way to
solve that problem or
at least chip away at that problem would
be to implement use money that you're
putting towards these things to put
executive orders to put the
counselors in schools because you're not
going to be able to go into somebody's
house and give them a father
no but you could remove uh you could
remove laws that accompany the welfare
state that encourage
uh single parent households right to get
twice the benefits
you could uh remove some of the laws in
the books that actually discourage
depending where you are um
family why not do both okay yeah i think
that's a good i think
that's right if we were if you were to
offer me yes it's a waste of money
but what we both agree to it's also
grossly unconstitutional
yeah yeah i mean look like i i think
that i understand where you're coming
and this is one thing i will say look
and don't
because women sometimes get offended
when i say this women naturally are more
empathetic than men
okay women naturally tend to be more
empathetic walk a mile in people's shoes
um and that's a good thing however i
also think that sometimes what ends up
happening
and this is what happens with laws like
these which i'm sure is largely drafted
by harris and biden said okay
and signed it whoever's puppeting them
yeah exactly
got no strings to hold me down um is
doing it under the guise of empathy but
it can end up causing more harm than
good
um and i think it's very important that
we look at people's constitutional
rights we look at the fact that
the only equalizer for example for a
woman with a guy
for a for a woman to ward off an
intruder or an attacker is a woman with
a firearm women are going to be weaker
than men this is true
they're over 500 000 to 3 million
defensive uses of firearms each year
a huge percentage of those are women and
laws like this would allow someone to
say
i don't think that someone will say my
ex-wife she's a crazy [ __ ] how often do
you hear that right and then go
we're taking away your guns you can come
get them back obviously it has to be
founded
right but it doesn't with these red
flags you have an example in new jersey
where a doctor
got uh a patient's guns taken away
because he kept leaving bad yelp reviews
i'm using the most extreme example to
make a point but this kind of stuff
happens
yeah because some states are really
loose with it i
i think in any situation where you have
a peer being able to
report another peer you're going to be
abused it also seems orwellian
yeah isn't it scary yeah it's just
why are they using all of this money
when they could be
it just this this country needs more
mental health the kids are not all right
yeah i think if we have more uh mental
health we'd have far fewer liberals
far fewer bidens because they seem to
think this is logical
this is sound reason it's yeah well
thank you so much emily yes
emily i appreciate you sitting down
thank you very much and uh thank you for
taking the time
there you have it folks where do you
line up on red flag laws
ghost guns just comment below let us
know and uh stay tuned for our next
installment
on voter id and why opposing it is kind
of racist
well you're still here on the internet
that's a that's a miracle
this is long and there are no cats
playing piano or
midgets on tricycles but uh look there
are other change my mind videos you can
click here there's some
new ones coming up and if you want to
support the show look you you guys all
know about mug club but
you can get some of these fight like
hell shirts at crowdershop.com that's
the best way to support us
um also if you know
someone in qatar
with oil money my number is not hard to
find